では よろしくお願いします
今日のテーマは ちょっと毎回話を聞いている方々が来るだろうということで
ちょっと作りましたけど
なんか顔を見ると 初めて参加している方々のそれほどお話を聞かない方々もいるように見えますから
もうちょっと紹介します
どんな言われでしょうかと
えーと あの仏教は この真理というものを発見しなさいというんですね
あの その真理という言葉のちょっと意味が違うんです
仏教は科学であっても
何であっても この人間のこの五感で見るものはあまり
正しいと思っていないんです
何でも我々は認識するんだけど
自分の都合で認識するんだと
だから私たち発見している科学でも
あれは人間の都合で人間のために
作っているもので発見するものであって
実際真理は何なのかということではありません
それでこのいろいろ知識などなどを得ると
人間が向上するんじゃなくて
欲やら怒りや見栄やらあれこれやとも
ありったけの煩悩が現れていくんですね
堕落するんですね 結局は
それで私たちの悩み 苦しみなどなどは
そのまま 戦うは競争するは
戦争を起こすは 全然差別するは
いくら勉強したっても
いくら科学発展したっても
問題は解決しないんですね
お釈迦様が発見したことは
一言葉で言えば この我々の認識そのものが捏造であると
一切の人間の この捏造っていうのは面白いことで
例えばこの草の束を見ると
私たちはただの草ではないか
もうゴミじゃないかとかね
これはもう生ゴミやとかね
なんとかしてゴミ扱いする
しかし それを見た山羊とか牛とかは
あ ごちそうだ 食べるものだとするんですね
で 例えば動物の死骸を見るとね
まあそれどんな動物ではなくて
ネズミとかね そういう死骸を見ると
カラスがごちそうだと思って
そこはもうパクパク食べる
人間がその死骸を見たら
気持ち悪い 不潔だ 早く処分しなくちゃという気持ちを作る
それから魚の死骸を見ると
あら 摩訶不思議にあ これおいしそうやとかね
で 豚 まあ死んで その死骸をね
いろいろ切って切って
もう置いてあると あ なかなか美味しそうな豚肉だなとかね
その時不潔やと思わないんですね
これ死骸だと思わないんですね
だから一体我々の認識というのはそんなもので
都合なんですね それは捏造と言うんです
捏 文字通り捏造なんです
捏造するためにはデータが必要なんです
データ全くもないところで捏造できません
それで捏造するのはどうしても自分の立場
自分の都合ということにもなります
捏造なんて何でもかんでもできませんよ
ある限りがあるんです
しかし 本当のことじゃないんです
知識というそのものが捏造であるならば
どうしましょうか 当てにならないんですね
それから我々は知識よりも大量に
一日のほとんどを思考ではなくて妄想に費やしているんです
妄想はなおさらダメなんです
妄想なら何でもできる
捏造は何でもできるわけじゃないんです
だから捏造はいくらかといえば思考なんですね
何でも思考できるわけじゃないんです
妄想なら自由自在 何でもできます
だから あまりにも我々は真理からかけ離れた生き方をしているんです
それでお釈迦様はこれを解消する方法を教えるんですね
その方法の集約して言えば
もっととりあえずまず先に
もう何でもいいんだから思考を止めなさいと
この思考を止める方法を教えているんです
この思考を止める それだけしか言ってないんだけど
思考を止める方法を実行してみると
ものの見事に我々は精神的に向上する
集中力はすごく上がってきて
すごい精神的にものすごい強い人間になる
心はみるみるうちに穏やかになっていく
それから知恵 知識の代わりに知恵が開発していくんです
で 知恵が完成したところで
思考は一切なくなるんです
妄想は一切なくなるんです
やってみようかなと思ったらできますけど
もう無意味であることを知っています
例えば花を見て これは結構きれいな花だと言えますが
これは捏造であることは知っているんです
だから思考はなくなるんですね
妄想はもうなくなるんです
で 知恵が完成しているんです
その人がもう完成した人間で
悟りに達した人で 普通の人間とは全く桁違い
仏陀はその道を教えているんです
すごい心理学的で科学的で科学なんですね
はい そこは基本的に覚えておいてください
今日の話はそこからの話なんです
それであの妄想を止めるために
私たちはこのヴィパッサナー瞑想という実況中継する
確認する作業 観察する作業を推薦しています
それはもう私たちはといったっても
この講演にもいろいろ経典を参考にして参考にしてみましたんですけど
やっぱりどこでも一貫して気づき
気づき 気づきなんですね
観察しなさいと ありのままに
ですから この方法はお釈迦様に説かれたたった一つのこれしかないんだと言っているんですね
それでお釈迦様に説かれたこの観察方法をやってみると
思考を止める方法をやってみると
なかなか大変 なかなか思考妄想は止めてくれませんね
止まってくれません 大変ですよ
だから修行者というのは結構厳しい目に遭います
仏教は苦行は何一つもないんです
ものすごい普通に誰にでもできます
何の修行も変な修行って何一つも説かれていないんです
ただ観察するだけ しかし
それでも妄想がどんどんどんどん現れてきて
現れてきて 心を汚してなかなかうまくいかない
はい ではどうしますか？ということは今日なんです
はい どうしても妄想は止められないなら
思考回路のグレードアップに挑戦しようということで
まず 思考って何なのかと考えていきます
普通は思考と妄想の差がないんです
まあ本当は思考であって
妄想はどうでも同じことなんですね
思考だと思って妄想することが多いようです
なぜならば 私たちは何か考えているんだと思ってはいるんだけど
実は妄想しているんです
妄想するのだと思って思考する人は少ないんです
これから妄想してやろうと思って
しっかりした思考するっていうのは
あれは大体ないんです
逆はありますね 今 私は大事なことを考えているんだよと
よく見るとただの妄想しているだけ
思考することになっても
大量の妄想が勝るのです
それで勉強とかね なんとかちゃんとしたことを思考しようと思っても
ものすごい大量に妄想が割り込んで割り込んで割り込んで割り込んで
10 分でできる思考がまあ 10 時間もかかってしまうということになるんです
ものすごく時間なくなるんです
今日 皆様覚えてほしいことがありまして
考える時も時間がいくんです
時間が経過するんです
よく覚えてください 例えば何かやろうと思ったら
当然時間という関係が次元が必要なんですね
どれぐらい時間がかかるのかと
どんなものにも ここからドアまで歩く歩きますと思ったら
ある時間がなくなるんです
瞬時にできません いつでも何やろうとも時間がなくなる
使う それで普通 皆様方はまあなんか仕事をする時は時間がかかるとかね
家の掃除をする時はちょっと時間がかかるとかね
洗濯するためには時間がかかるとか
そういう物理的なことに時間がかかると思っているんですよね
しかし ものすごいたくさん時間が思考に
妄想にかかるんです それで何か大きい問題が起きたら
じゃあ 1週間考えさせてくださいとかね
言うでしょうに 1週間考えてないんだけど
妄想しているだけで 妄想するんだから 1 週間がかかっちゃうんですね
妄想さえなければ瞬時にできますよ
思考っていうのはすごい早いんです
思考はスピードアップするためには
妄想を減らさなくちゃいけないんです
例えば 釘付けになって本を読んだり
勉強したりする場合は早いんです
釘付けになっているんだから
あまり妄想は割り込まないんですね
テレビを見ながら 音楽も聞きながら
もう手も足も振りながらやると
もう 30分の勉強には 3時間ということになってしまうんです
そういうことで 思考にも妄想にも時間がかかるということを覚えておいてください
我々は思考すると 思考はもう 1 分すると
だいたい 59 分は妄想は交ぜてやっているんです
こうして見ると 思考にかかった時間はほんの瞬間なんです
他は全部時間の無駄なんです
で 課題が与えられた時
解決するべき問題がある時
具体的なデータから何かの結論を結論に達する時
計画などを立てる時は思考が優先になるんです
どんな時思考するのかで
そんな時は思考するんですね
あまり分かりやすいんですね
何か計画を立てなくちゃいけない
その場合はちゃんと思考する
あるいは思考の場合はデータが必要なんですね
妄想の場合はデータが要りません
はい そういうものを我々は一直ずっとやっているわけじゃないんです
たまたまでしょ 思考するのは
他の時間は妄想なんですね
はい 妄想って何なのかと
この認識の流れにターゲットはないんですね
もう認識流れというのは妄想なんですね
ターゲットはない 何の目的があって妄想しているのかということないんです
ただ妄想する 何のためだと聞いても本人はわからないんです
論理 理性 具体性 現実性などに耐えないんですね
論理的に妄想する人はいませんよ
具体的に妄想する人もいません
現実で現実だったら妄想じゃないんだからね
だから現実的にもうありえないんですね
ただ単に妄想 何の根拠もない
結論は出ないんですね
いくら妄想しても結論はないんです
だからやるわやるわ やるわやるわやるわ
もう精神的に病気になって自己破壊になるまでやるんです
結論はないんです 妄想には
思考にはあります 数学の問題出されたら思考します
論理的に それで結論があります
それで終わり やったぞと
それで話終わり 気分がいいんです
妄想は逆 結論がないんです
何かの結論に達しても
複数の選択肢が出て さらに妄想したり悩んだりするんですね
時々妄想してね あ こうしましょうかと何となく決めるんです
いい ちょっと待って そうではなくて
こうした方がいいんじゃないか
また別な結論出るんです
やっぱりそれよりもこの方がいいんじゃないかと
それで結論がいくつか出てくるんですよ
それだけで頭がぐちゃぐちゃになっちゃうんです
それで悩み どうしよう
どうしよう どうしよう
あれもやりたい これもやりたい
これもやりたいとかね
結論ないんで 結論のようなものが出ても頭こんがらがっちゃうんですね
用事があって妄想するのではないのです
何か用事があって妄想してるわけじゃないんですね
ただの時間の浪費 用事があると思考するんです
感情が妄想を引き起こすのです
なんでも絶え方 もうもう終わらない
限りない妄想するんですか？というと
感情があるんですね 感情がこういう頭を回転させるんです
それが妄想というんですね
感情には理屈はないでしょうに
具体性もないでしょうに
例えば何々か何かを好き
なんで？と言ったってわからないでしょうに
だって私はソフトクリームが大好きやと言ったら
なんででしょうかねと
わかりませんね ただ好きだけ
だから感情には理屈は何もないんです
だからまあ感情によって
あのソフトクリーム食べたい
あの国のソフトクリーム食べたいとかね
フランスのものを食べたい
イタリアのジェラート食べたいとかね
あれやこれやといくらでも妄想できますからね
はい だから感情入りましたから
もう感情の同義語は煩悩なんですね
妄想と煩悩 無知欲 怒りという煩悩で
これ感情ですね 妄想が起こる
清らかな思考でいる時でさえも
煩悩は裏で働くので 煩悩が突然噴火します
怒り 欲 嫉妬などなどの感情で妄想しているんです
憎しみとかね あるといくらでも妄想する
時々しっかりした思考をする時もありますよ
まあまとめな人間になりたいとかね
じゃあまともな人間になるためにちょっと勉強しなくちゃとかね
それでいろいろ参考文献を探して読ん
はしますけど だからといって感情がなくなったわけじゃないんです
感情は裏で回転していて
突然噴火するんです 皆
煩悩があるから妄想を始めるが
妄想によってさらに煩悩が起こるので
止めることはたやすいことではありません
それで問題がありますね
とんでもない問題 感情で妄想が起こる
妄想が感情をフィードバックする
妄想するたびに欲が出ますね
何か誰か見ただけで気に入ってしまったら
あの人は可愛いと それからずっと焼き付けちゃって
頭の中でね あの人は可愛いなとかね
電話番号聞いておいた方がよかったなとかね
あれこれやと考える 妄想すればするほど
あの欲がどんどん強くなって膨張していくんですね
欲が感情が膨張すると
さらに妄想する 妄想するとまた感情が大きくなるという
とんでもない悪循環になって
自己破壊になるまでやるんです
この悪循環を断つように努力しても
また妄想の罠にはまってしまうんですよ
じゃあ悪循環をなんとか断ち切って
もうカットしましょうと
妄想をやめましょうと思っても
結局はまた始めてしまうんです
はい 次はなぜ我々は人間は思考と妄想するのかっていうことはね
あんまりその場合言わなくてもいいとは思いますけど
ちょっと難しいことを言います
輪廻転生 輪廻転生している生命は
感情を生きる衝動にしているんです
仏教はこの人生だけ人生だと思ってないんだからね
ずっと無限に流れるんですね
命のエネルギーが で 命のエネルギーが流れる場合は
感情ですね 衝動は わかりやすいでしょ
皆さんは何かすごい好きなことがあったら頑張るでしょ
で 例えばね 何かもう勉強したり
もう何でもやる あれやりたい
これやりたいという何か目的が出たら
だから苦しくはないんですね
例えばチャンピオンベルト取りたいと思っちゃうと
何でしたっけ？プロレスラーがね
ベルト取りたいと思ったら
もうどんな苦労してでも訓練します
あのタレントさんになりたい人々とかね
もうすっごい初めは苦労するんですね
いろいろお笑い芸人とかそういう世界なんですけど
ものすごい苦労するんですよ
お金がないわ 食べるものはないわ
もう まあそれでもそれでも何年も頑張るっていう
で それでもしかすると売れる可能性はありますね
売れる可能性あるんだから
それにかけてどんな苦労でもするんですね
だから感情がないと なかなか頑張れないでしょう
感情によってこの真理にも気づかないんです
仏教は生きることは苦であると
生きるもんじゃないと思ってるんです
輪廻なんかするもんじゃないんだと
生きること自体が苦であると
今日はその説明はいたしません
生きることは苦であるならば
知ってるはずなんです
皆様方も でもどうも妄想に妄想にふけっているんだからね
そんなこと言われたっても
楽しいこといっぱいあると思っちゃうんですね
それが感情なんですね
だから楽しいことがあると
生きる苦しみはもうないがしろにするんです
どんな苦労もする 例えば
エベレストを登りたいと思ったらとんでもないことでしょうね
あんなのやったって何の意味もないんです
エベレスト登ったんだから
何か人類に貢献したことがある
何もないんです ただ自然を汚っただけ
それから厳しい 今決まりありますけど
全部ゴミ 微妙なものでも持って戻ってくださいとかね
ああいうところでゴミを捨てたったりしたら
もうものすごい寒いところだから
ずっとそのまんまなんですね
だからエベレストを登ることになっちゃ
みんなもう気楽に もうもう恐ろしい自然破壊
自然汚染する羽目になってしまう
そのために何か私にとってはバカバカバカバカらしくてね
しかし 難しいことに挑戦すると
あの感情が出たらもう何でもやりますよ
で もう死の覚悟でやるんです
ちょっとしたことで死ぬ
だからいい加減にしなさいと
じゃがいもでも植えたらどうですかと
理性的ですけど その方が楽でしょうに
こんな苦しい こんな嫌なことやれば苦しいと思うんですね
畑でジャガイモを作ることは
どういうことになってますかね
人間が その代わりにエベレストを登る 1
年  2年  3年も訓練して
訓練して 訓練して ものすごいお金かかって
そういうことで この感情があると
生きる苦しみはもうないがしろにする
すっごくバカになるんです
苦しいなのに気づかないと認めない
生きること自体が幸福だ
楽しみだと錯覚して 生きること輪廻に固執するんですね
我々はずっと輪廻に固執しています
もう生きていきたいんですね
生き続けたいんですね
死にたくはないんです
どんな苦しいことにあっても
どんなひどい目にあっても
やっぱりそれでも生きていきたいと思うんです
はい そういうことで感情がある
だったら思考妄想する羽目になります
思考妄想すると感情がどんどん大きくなってきて
我々は輪廻転生させるんです
苦しませるんです なんで気づかないのかというと
もうこの感情のせいなんですね
まあそれはまあ 生きることは苦なんですけど
感情で楽しみで 妄想で紛らわすんです
妄想しないと いてもたってもいられなくなります
だって  1 日の思考する時間っていうのは
せいぜい 10 分  15 分ですよ
じゃあ残る時間何する？電車に乗って会社までは 1 時間半かかるとしましょう
何度も思考することはないですよ
黙っていればいいんだからね
いられると思う 思考することはないんだからね
思い存分妄想するんですよ
そうすると  1 時間は何のことなく終わってしまうんです
そういうことで 生きることは隠す
生きることは 苦であることは妄想で隠すんですね
欲 怒り 嫉妬 傲慢 高慢などの感情があると
生きることにチャレンジできるようになるんです
チャレンジします 生きていようと
これは欲 怒り 嫉妬 憎しみ
傲慢 それでチャレンジしているんです
したがって 妄想は不可欠なものになります
妄想 最悪なんです 生きるものには妄想は不可欠なんです
しかし 妄想は自己破壊的で
苦しみは拡大する結果になるんです
妄想っていうのは自己破壊なんです
なんで原子爆弾まで作っているのかと
なんでミサイルまで作るのかと
なんで自然が壊す 壊れてしまったのかと
妄想の結果ですよ 怒り欲の結果なんでしょうに
そこでこの精神病というものがありますね
いろんな精神病っていうのは無数にありますよ
私は今もある心理学の本を読んでいるんです
初めてびっくりしました
心理学はただ精神的な病気の人ではなくて
ごく普通のノーマルな人々の心理状況も研究しましょうとなんか始めたみたいんです
で 今までは病気の人々のね
なになに症 なになに症
なになに症とかね いろいろ名前あるわあるわあるわ
体の病気の名前よりは
精神的な病気の名前だけはたくさんありますけど
心理医者はもう治療する方法知らないんです
精神的な病気にはないんです
ただ薬を処方するだけ
カウンセリングとかいろいろありますけどね
あまり治らないんですね
アメリカなんかはね カウンセラーに行くのはごく普通
当たり前のことになってます
あまり東洋の方がなんかもう頭がイカれてますけど
カウンセラーに行くのはなんかちょっと恥ずかしいと思っているんです
アメリカではそれはかっこいいんですね
頭がイカれてるっていうことはね
だから誰でもちょっと金があれば
まあみんなにいるんですね
心理カウンセラーは しかし治らないんですよ
で 仏教が言うのは この一切の精神病気は妄想なんです
妄想の結果なんです 私のことを嫌われているんだと妄想してみてください
どんな結果になるかわからないんです
だから妄想 自分のこと嫌われているかと
知らないでしょうに まあ正しく言えば
我々に慈しみがないんだから
誰でもみんなのこと嫌っているんですよね
なのに一人がやっぱり自分のことを嫌われていると
何様ですかね 初めから嫌われているんですよ
みんな他人に そこで妄想があるでしょ
自分を可愛がってほしいというね
自分を可愛がって高く評価するのは当たり前という妄想が入り込んじゃって
それからもう考えて考えて考えて
いろんな病気を発生するんです
だから一切の精神病気は
これ断言的に言えます
精神病というものは 何であろうとも原因は一つ
妄想 だから治療もたった一つ
妄想を止めるようにアドバイスしなくちゃいけないんです
で 思考は人間が生きるために必要なものを得る手段なのです
はい 妄想を置いておいて
思考 思考っていうのはね
そうですが 自分の都合でしょ
ね そうっていうのは だから論文をねつ造する人も何か得るんですね
ねつ造した論文を出しちゃって
だから思考が必要になるんです
あのヘビに生まれつき毒があり
鳥に翼とくちばしがあるから
思考しなくても生きていられます
ヘビに毒があるんだから得るべきものは得られます
敵から身を守ることもできます
この鳥たちとか モンクでしたっけ？ヘビを食べるんですよ
猛毒のコブラでも モンゴウズがパクパクとヘビを食べるんだけど
ヘビも食べられないように攻撃しますね
しかし 足 足が速くない
足はないんですね 初めから
だから逃げられないんですね
ヘビは それでコブラだったら傘を見せて攻撃しようとするんです
モンゴウズに一回だけでも触れたら
口 口はモンゴウズが死にます
だからこれはもう本当に命かけて戦うんですよ
大体はもうモンゴウスは勝ちます
大体は モンゴウスの餌ですからね
蛇は で 勝ったら食べられちゃいます
しかし あの毒はちょっとでも体に触れたらもう死ぬ
象でも死にますよ だからゾウさんが森の中で歩く時はとっても気をつけるんです
小さな動物でも踏まないんです
まあゾウがヘビを踏んだらね
まあ傘開く時間はないんですけど
でも一応踏まないんです
よく見て ものすごく目がよろしいしね
よく見て歩くんです はい
それで他の生き物と同じく
人間にも生まれつき 据えている武器
道具は知識 思考です だからもう真面目に思考を変えてください
この知識っていうのは
毒 蛇の毒と同じなんです
どうったことないんです
例えば 蛇の毒を抜かれたら蛇が死にますかね？死にませんよ
で 飼ってる蛇とかはね
あの牙も取って毒も抜かれた
大丈夫です 餌くれますから
生きていられます 人間も知識がなくても生きていられますけど
誰かが食べ物くれないとね
で そういうことになります
で トラもね すごい体力も体に力があってね
もう走れるし 木も登れるし
獲物取れますけど で で
虎にはこの顎が強い 牙がある
これはすねがね すごいきついんですよ
これで一発やられちゃうと
もうかなり深い傷跡を作る
それで虎とかそういう系統の動物たちは
喉が噛むでしょ 噛んだらもうもうどうにもならん
もう失血死死にます しかし
歯が落ちたらどうしますかね
野生で歯が落ちたらもう終わり
死ぬしかないんです あの太いすね
だから猫と同じく研いだだけではシャープにならないんですね
どんどんどんどんこれ鈍くなってくるの
なんかブラシ 筆と同じくなってしまうんですよ
先っぽが それだったらもう獲物取れなくなるんですね
それで死ぬんです しかし
我々はこのハイエナじゃなくて
このジャガーとかね クーガーとか虎とか飼ってみたらどうですかね
歯が全部落ちたっても生きていられます
それが全部もう粉々になっても生きていられます
で 餌もらってるんだからね
そういうことで 私たちの知識ってのはそんなに自慢するもん
ものじゃないんです ただ生きるためにある道具なんです
それは当然捏造なんですよ
不公平ですよ で 動物に毒があるんだから
ヘビに毒があるんだからといって人間まで噛んだりするでしょう
それいいわけないでしょうに
だからネズミやらカエルやら飲み込むかもしれませんだけど
もうネズミにしてみればもうえらい迷惑でしょうに
それで肉食動物がいるんだからといって
体力能力があるんだからといって
小食動物にとってみればもう大変迷惑でしょうね
しかし それほど大きい問題じゃないんです
人間にも知識があります
生きていられるためには不可欠ですが
迷惑といえばものすごい迷惑なんです
だから何が違いますかと
人間と他の動物生命は
残念ながら知識を育てなくてはならないんですね
もう一つ 人間の場合はもっとかわいそう
で 猫やらもうライオンやらね
学校に行かなくても大丈夫です
どのように身を隠して獲物を取るのかともよく知ってるんです
人間は学ばないと知識を
生まれる時は能力だけを持って生まれるんです
それから文字を書いたり
算数を勉強したり 図工をやったり
あれやこれやもうたくさん学ばなくちゃいけないんですね
学んで学んで もう生きる武器をしっかりするんです
やがて大量破壊兵器まで作る
その武器で だから無意味に殺すっていうことは
人間だけ この武器を開発したり
毒を開発したり 大量破壊兵器を開発したりするのは
まあもうネズミにも負ける
性格的にはね 人間というのはネズミの方がかっこいいんです
余計なことをしません
迷惑ですが 必要なところで止めるんです
それ以上はやりません
必要以上に破壊しません
はい そういうことで 我々人間は生きるためには思考しなくてはいけないんです
で なんで仏教は思考をやめなさいと言うんですかね
生きることっていうのは
それほどアホなことはないんです
それは極限に無知な行為なんです
解脱しなくちゃいけない
生きることは苦なんです
苦しいんです よく観察してみると
科学的に見ると だったらそんな苦労して生きていなくても
そういうわけで この脱出しなさいと言うんだから
思考はすごい迷惑になるんです
知恵が必要になるんです
はい 次 思考っていうのはだから停止できるのかっていう問題
仏教は何としてでも生きなさいではなく
苦しみを乗り越え 超えることを説く
知識は捏造で都合で主観なのです
真理 事実ではありません
真理を発見することは知恵と言います
本当に真理ではありませんよ
例えば 死んだネズミの死骸を見たら
ああ 気持ち悪いと思っちゃう
自分が正しいと思うんです
カラスがおいしいと思っちゃうんですね
それは捏造で しかし カラスにおいしいという
気持ち作ったのはあの死んだネズミですかね
だと思っちゃうでしょ
では 我々に気持ち悪いとさせたのは死んだネズミでしょ
だから犯人はネズミですかね
もうとっくに死んでるんだから何もしませんよ
死んだネズミがカラスが来ると
あ ごちそうの顔をしてやるぞと
人間見てる あ 気持ち悪い顔をしてやるぞとは思わないんです
ポイントは カラスも人間もありのままに見てないんです
データを捏造しちゃったんです
そこでカラスの目に映したデータは何ですか？と
我々の目に映るデータは何ですか？で
捏造する前に知ってほしいんです
それで初めて真理の発見なんです
花見ていきなりきれいともう決まってるんですね
それが捏造 その前に目に何が触れたのかと
耳に音が触れたとたん
ああ 音楽だ ああ クラシック
クラシックだとか なんとか決めちゃったりして
ああ ベートーベンだとかね
随分早いことね 象の その前に目に触れる音って何なのかと
知らなくちゃいけない
だから結構訓練が必要ですよ
かなりの集中力が必要なんです
音そのものを認識するために
はい それできる能力は知恵と呼ぶんです
知恵は現れるたびに 生きることは楽になり
幸福になるんです 知恵が現れると
初めて生きることは楽になるんです
知恵がないんだからさらに苦しいんです
で 知恵が現れて心の汚れをなくし
完全たる平安に達するためには
まず正しくない思考妄想を停止させる必要があります
仏教の修行は思考妄想を制御するところから始まるんです
このこれ ちょっと冗談なんです
で 制御するところから始まるって言っても
それだけなんで 仏教の修行は
で 停止したらもう悟りに達してるんです
だから初めはなんだ こんなシンプルなやり方で
もっとかっこいい宗教あるんじゃないかなと思っちゃいますから
いえ これスタートだけですよ
言うんですけど スタート時点でもう終了もそちらにあるんです
はい それで基本的なところはイントロダクションのところは終わります
妄想は止められない 妄想が問題の原因であるとわかっても
妄想を制御する修行に励んでも
妄想の渦巻きに落ちてしまうんです
いくら仏教を勉強して張り切って
じゃあ修行してみるぞと思ってもうまくいかないんです
すぐ妄想の渦巻きにやられちゃいます
難しい たとえで言えば
人間に呼吸を止めなさいと言えるようなことです
妄想をやめなさいと言っちゃう
なんか呼吸やめなさいということと同じく感じるんです
不可能でしょうと ありえないでしょう
と思っちゃうんです すごい難しい
強烈な集中力 落ち着き
理性 ありのままに観察できる能力
真理と因果法則の発見
知恵の開発などが揃うと妄想が停止するんです
そんな簡単じゃないんです
だから難しいっていうことはわかるでしょうに
集中力がないならば もう難しい
できない で 理性がないとまたできない
落ち着いてないとまたできない
因果法則をわからないと発見しないと思考は止まらないんです
ですから 釈尊が徐々に進む方法を説かれたのです
どうしようもないんだけど
お釈迦様の弟子たちはというか
人間はね もう救いようもないんですね
お釈迦様は最初はね もうやめると思ったんだからね
最初はね もうやめますと
これは無理だと 人間には
だから嫌々なさった説法なんですよ
45年間も 説法したくなかったんです
言っても言っても言っても
シンプルな事実なのに
全く妄想の壁を破らないんです
何か変なことを妄想しちゃうんです
だからお釈迦様はしょうがない
まあ幼稚園児に言ってるような感じで
じゃあ同じ色のものを集めましょうとかね
はい 同じ形は何なのかとかね
ブロックと木で作ってるものありますね
三角形だったら穴があって
はい どちらに入るでしょうかと
それで子供は丸いものに入れてみて
四角いもの入れて入らないんですね
それでなんとかして三角の穴に入れちゃうと
ああ よくできましたとかね
ああ よくできましたと褒めたりして
それで輪っかをあげて
どんどん大きい輪っかからどんどん小さい小さい
最後に小さい輪っかになるように棒があってね
そこに組み立ててみなさいとかね
そういうところから始めてますから
お釈迦様も じゃあ幼稚園児に説法するぞということであります
でもお釈迦様の幼稚園はね
相当これも大変です